[Music]
dude dude come to be scared sometimes
huh it's bad it's just a dog it's a
pretty violent I understand that some of
truth behaviors would be upsetting but I
urge you to find a place where he feels
safe I think it would be good for him
good for all of us
oh my goodness like that how much bit of
a nice dude
[Music]
and it's like he was broken before and
put back together who's this handsome
chap ROMs
how'd you come up with that he tells me
all sorts of things okay I just think
it's a little bit creepy is this your
new friend Brahms
what are some of the things you talk
about the other families he's lovely
[Music]
I'm gonna take this all away from him
yes just always that first something is
happening to him he knew your boy would
find your mommy I love you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I know I came all the way up here
there's nothing left
there are people out there worth saving
people that are left another kind of
people weren't saving there is an
elevator in the elevator you press the
button to the floor with no name behind
those doors is a life you always tremor
[Music]
the planet but here
this weekend you will be our guests
here anything and everything is possible
no service it's not everything is
possible
good evening I'm mr. Orrick let me
officially welcome you to Fantasy Island
[Applause]
I'm curious how this all works what if
your fantasy involves a person from your
life Holograms
like to [ __ ] what if it's somebody who
died - so what's your fantasy revenge on
a childhood bully your life is about to
change
[Music]
I hope you're ready
that is really good hologram there is
only one fantasy per guess and you must
see your fantasy through no matter what
oh my god
that's really hurt this is not what I
meant
what the hell is this place
people died here the islands twisting
what we asked
weren't brought here to have our own
fantasies we were brought here to be a
part of something else
I'm your friend anything you say
[Music]
what is storytelling storytelling
started with our indigenous people can
anyone give me an example of a myth or a
story they're afraid of Lucas he found a
part of a man in the woods today part of
a man I guess the other half was found
in the mine all this has got to be an
animal right
[Music]
no animal that I've ever seen something
is going on with Lukas these drugs
belongs to a student of mine this was
what was in the lion
it's what diabolical spirit this is a
myth
for you yeah
now connect a jakoli suckin little
he's not your responsibility
he has no responsibility
he's here
[Music]
how would you feel about going to the
mountains of Christmas grace really
wants to get to know you guys
[Music]
don't leave here with the kids if you're
not feeling until God I'm feeling fine I
can do a couple days that's right
everyone commits goes down
what is this
the cars only
we're leaving we can't leave we're stuck
here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
nine-one-one
what did your emergency
[Music]
hello hello
are you there
is anyone with you
did you go to a safe area
hello Michael I've learned you since you
were a child leave a gift
you always have if there's an answer to
the disease we'll find it
I should have died years ago
why am I still here if not to fix this
I have a rare blood disease and I'm not
that at a time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly legal
I want to see you get hurt more than you
already have this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
and one from time
increased strength is speed
the ability to use echolocation
and then overpowering earth to consume
blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
Michael Morbius got tired of doing the
old good guy thing up what's up doc
what's the last thing you remember daddy
he said we had to route the reason you
survived it's because you're a very
uncommon girl you're not alone not
anymore
do you know a mutants or would anyone
like to she had their first time brain I
was 13 I thought what if it's a dream I
just lost control Sam I started
panicking people got hurt
Roberto my girlfriend Bernhard Viviana
I killed 18 men one by
[Music]
better than a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
I saw something I don't think she wanted
me to see
I don't think we're here to cut better
this place takes your grade it's for you
it makes your live through it until it
kills you is there we can get out of
this together
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Anna Fox there are some things that
need to be said about me I have an
anxiety disorder I'm not prepared for
visitors I'm a Acorah phobic
I can't go outside
[Applause]
[Music]
you let some of the outside come in your
neighbor from across the street pretty
sure you're not supposed to be hippies
without a hop
her name is Jane Russell she's become a
friend like your earrings oh thanks I
gift from an old boyfriend
does your husband mind
[Music]
our family's complicated
I
[Music]
my neighbor changed she's been stabbed
my PD
why is he here mr. Russell believes that
you made a mistake never met my wife we
spent the evening together I'm Jane
Russell she's not Jane I know what I saw
the doctor said that your meds
can cause hallucinations why are you
protecting them they're all hiding
something
her earring it's in their house you're
playing with the Roma family do they
know you're here alone
911 somebody hazing my house don't go
looking into other people's houses you
won't like what you see
[Music]